Новини дня «heute» з Мітрієм Сіріним.
Доброго вечора!
Катю, франкфуртський ФК «Айнтрахт»
є новоспеченим переможцем Ліги Європи.
Сп'янілі від захоплення вболівальники хочуть
влаштувати їм неймовірний прийом
біля ратуші Ремер.
Так, чемпіони вже їдуть туди. Дощ ще не почався,
але, думаю, сьогодні для всіх це байдуже.
Найважливіші теми сьогодні:
Гарячі дискусії в парламенті Німеччини:
Канцлер Олаф Шольц пообіцяв Україні подальшу
допомогу, а опозиція вважає, що цього замало.
Федеральний конституційний суд Німеччини
затвердив обов’язкову вакцинацію
для персоналу в лікарнях і
будинках догляду за літніми людьми.
Футбольна казка стала реальністю:
після перемоги в Лізі Європи у Севільї
Франкфурт святкує та радісно вітає своїх героїв
з «Айнтрахту».
Війна, зміна курсу, постачання зброї.
Канцлер Шольц замало коментує свою
політику, такою є критика в його бік.
Лідер опозиції Мерц у парламенті Німеччини
дорікає йому у зволіканні та ваганнях.
Томас Райхарт розповість про те, чи зміг канцлер
чіткіше прокоментувати свої дії в сьогоднішній
заяві уряду,
та якою була реакція лідера CDU цього разу.
На повістці дня заява уряду.
Відбудеться дуель
між канцлером і лідером опозиції,
між Олафом Шольцом і Фрідріхом Мерцом.
Майже через три місяці після промови
про зміну курсу
Шольц підтвердив, що підтримає Україну зброєю
у війні проти Росії.
Росія не повинна виграти цю війну.
Україна має вистояти.
Тому я хочу висловитись цілком чітко:
допомога державі, яка зазнала жорстокого нападу,
не є ескалацією.
Канцлер також не погоджується з тими,
хто закликає до швидкого припинення вогню,
щоб піти назустріч Путіну.
Миру, продиктованого Росією, не буде.
Тому що українці цього не приймуть.
І ми також.
Тому ми допомагаємо Україні, також у військовій сфері.
Ми робимо це обмірковано, зважено,
та в тісній координації на міжнародному рівні.
Фрідріх Мерц натомість вважає, що уряд
повинен менше голосувати за обіцяне постачання зброї,
а швидше зброю передавати.
Насправді ж, варто зауважити,
що за останні декілька тижнів
з Німеччини взагалі не було постачань.
Що ви робите?
У яку гру ви з нами всіма бавитесь,
також і з німецькою громадськістю?
Мерц покладає відповідальність за це
зокрема на міністерку оборони Німеччини.
Нещодавно її розкритикували за
суперечливий політ її сина
на вертольоті Бундесверу.
Тому моя вам порада:
попрощайтеся з цією міністеркою якнайшвидше.
У будь-якому разі вам доведеться це зробити
протягом найближчих кількох тижнів або місяців.
Партія AfD стверджує,
що війна проти України – це не війна проти Німеччини.
Ліві також продовжують виступати проти
постачань зброї.
Хто дійсно вірить в те, що Росію,
найбільшу атомну державу світу,
можна поставити на коліна військовими засобами,
той просто помиляється.
Навпаки.
Такий курс є дуже небезпечним.
Шольц обіцяє Україні мільярди на відбудову,
але виступає проти швидкого вступу до ЄС.
Принаймні в цьому питанні з боку Мерца
немає заперечень.
Україні потрібні гроші для того, щоб
держава могла функціонувати.
За інформацією від України,
у її бюджеті є брак коштів у розмірі майже
п'яти мільярдів євро щомісяця.
На зустрічі міністрів фінансів країн G7
в Кеніґсвінтері міністр фінансів Німеччини
Лінднер оголосив про надання одного мільярду
євро короткострокової допомоги.
Також інші країни G7
пообіцяли фінансову допомогу.
У Вашингтоні також йдеться про дуже велику
суму грошей для України.
Багатомільярдний пакет допомоги.
Сенат США затвердив його декілька хвилин тому.
Ельмар Тевессен зараз у Вашингтоні.
Затверджено пакет допомоги Україні на
40 мільярдів доларів.
Неймовірна сума.
Наскільки важливою та цінною є така сума?
Це має величезне значення,
щось подібне майже ніколи не трапляється у Вашингтоні.
Президент просив приблизно 33 мільярди доларів,
натомість Конгрес надав 40 мільярдів доларів.
Половина суми призначена для збройної допомоги
Україні: на зенітні комплекси та
артилерійські установки з великою дальністю.
8 мільярдів економічної допомоги Україні,
загалом 5 мільярдів на подолання
світової продовольчої кризи.
Таке рішення великої більшості в Сенаті
засвідчує довготривалу підтримку в перспективі.
Вони хочуть показати, що стоятимуть
на боці України ще довго після цієї війни.
Для того, щоб ці зусилля не були марними
для США, Європи та для їхніх спільних цінностей.
Дякую, Елмаре Тевессене.
Сьогодні президент України підтвердив те,
що військові експерти вже давно прогнозували.
Зеленський готує своїх людей до більш тривалої
війни й планує подовження воєнного
стану ще на три місяці.
Різні трактування щодо становища солдатів
Маріупольського металургійного заводу є й надалі.
Лютен Лайнгос розповість детальніше.
Вони вже не чинять опору,
перевага нападника знищила його.
Саме такий посил мають ці знімки.
Їх було зроблено за дорученням російського уряду.
Їхньою метою є демонстрація того,
що про українських полонених добре піклуються.
Умови тут більше ніж прийнятні.
Є матраци, простирадла, достатньо їжі.
Тут всього вистачає.
Також російська пропаганда демонструє знімки
з поліклініки, де фігурують
українські полоненні з такими словами:
До мене добре ставляться.
Ніхто мене не ображає ні фізично, ні морально.
Влада в Києві навпаки намагається підтримувати
високий моральний дух людей ﻿записами,
де українські поліціянти роздають допомогу
населенню на сході.
Водночас Володимир Зеленський заявив
людям, що війна буде тривалішою.
Ми зобов'язані прогнати окупантів
і гарантувати Україні реальну безпеку.
Тому я підписав указ про продовження
режиму воєнного стану на 90 днів.
Водночас Зеленський дає людям
на окупованих територіях між Маріуполем
і Херсоном надію, що Україна їх визволить.
Також і Запорізьку АЕС.
У Запоріжжі є якраз протилежні побоювання.
Місто лише за кілька кілометрів від бойових дій
і наразі є підконтрольним Україні.
Майже щодня тут очікують на те,
що Росія спробує завоювати місто.
Фінляндія та Швеція
офіційно подали заявки на членство в НАТО,
а Туреччина як держава-член альянсу досі їх відхиляє.
На фоні цього почали докладати величезних
зусиль, щоб змінити позицію Анкари.
США налаштовані оптимістично,
президент Байден прийняв сьогодні
президента Фінляндії та
прем'єрміністерку Швеції в Білому домі.
Флоріан Нойган детальніше про заплановане
посилення НАТО на північному фланзі й опір цьому.
У саду Білого дому вони сьогодні запланували
єдине: творити фото для підручників з історії.
Такими жестами, такими реченнями як ці.
Фінляндія та Швеція зроблять НАТО сильнішою.
Сьогодні я пишаюся тим, що маю можливість сказати,
що США цілком і повністю їх підтримують.
Внесення нового запису до книги історії
все ще залежить від умов з боку Туреччини.
Президент Туреччини сьогодні повторив
свої докори, що, мовляв, обидві країни
підтримують курдські терористичні організації.
Ми вже сказали відповідальним особам в НАТО,
що ми проти вступу Фінляндії та Швеції.
Наша позиція є незмінною.
Президент Фінляндії відповів
на це звинувачення безпосередньо у Вашингтоні.
Ми дуже серйозно ставимося до тероризму.
Ми засуджуємо тероризм у всіх його формах.
І ми беремо активну участь у боротьбі з ним.
Багато хто підозрює, що Туреччину більше
турбує постачання зброї.
Наприклад таких винищувачів зі США.
Про це сьогодні під час візиту до Данії заявив
Генеральний секретар НАТО:
Коли такий важливий союзник, як Туреччина,
висловлює занепокоєння щодо безпеки,
то єдиним виходом є сісти разом за стіл перемовин.
Представники Швеції та Фінляндії сьогодні взяли участь
у зустрічі головнокомандувачів НАТО
як партнери, але поки не як члени.
Бюджетний комітет парламенту Німеччини
ухвалив давно визріле рішення.
Колишній канцлер та голова СДПН Ґерхард Шредер
залишиться без свого бюро в парламенті, що
фінансується державою, та без штатних посад.
З початку війни Шредера все частіше критикують
через його близькість до Путіна та
через посади в російських енергетичних компаніях.
Європарламент навіть хоче внести Шредера
до санкційного списку ЄС.
Щодо Шлезвіґ-Гольштайну: нову «редакцію»
коаліції «Ямайка» знято з обговорення.
А разом з цим і бажану коаліцію прем'єрміністра
від CDU Даніеля Ґюнтера.
Під час попередніх переговорів щодо
утворення коаліції, він сказав, що йому дуже
прикро через це.
Ґюнтер хотів і надалі керувати з Зеленими та FDP,
хоча міг би мати більшість лише з однією з партій.
Щодо коронавірусу:
Це питання було дуже суперечливим від початку,
але Федеральний конституційний суд Німеччини
вирішив цю проблему:
обов’язок вакцинації в будинках для літніх людей
і в медичних установах є законним.
З середини березня його дія поширюється на всіх
працівників закладів догляду за немічними, медичних
установ та клінік.
Погляд на ситуацію в Німеччині показує
що погляди на вакцинацію сильно відрізняються:
у Північному Рейні-Вестфалії, як і в багатьох інших
федеральних землях,
майже 10% працівників не вакциновані.
У Шлезвіг-Гольштейні їх близько 3%,
а у Саксонії понад 30%.
Бірґіт Франке.
Соціальна працівниця Ґабріела Паулі вже 23 роки
працює в будинку для літніх людей св.Гедвіґа
у Віттенбурзі.
Вона дуже любить свою роботу.
Проте вона не хоче вакцинуватись від коронавірусу.
Вона боїться вакцини.
Її турбує питання, як події розвиватимуться далі.
Я все ж дотримуватимусь своєї позиції
і, можливо, через це втрачу роботу,
хоча я усім серцем люблю те, чим займаюсь.
Мушу сказати, що це сильно змінить моє життя.
Адже це тривалий відрізок мого життя.
Федеральний конституційний суд затвердив
обов'язкову вакцинацію
для медсестер, лікарів та працівників лікарень.
Вакцинація важлива для захисту людей
похилого віку та хворих.
З іншого боку, мінуси для працівників професій,
для яких вакцинація є обов'язковою, незначні.
Федеральний міністр охорони здоров'я
погоджується з таким рішення.
Запровадження в установах обов’язкової вакцинації
допомогло запобігти загибелі
ще більшої кількості людей
від хвилі омікрону, з якою ми зараз боремося.
Однак рада медсестер хоче загального
зобов'язання вакцинуватися.
Восени буде нова хвиля.
Ми це знаємо, тому, як асоціація
повинні подбати про те, щоб запобігти цій інфекції.
Несправедливо залишати цю справу
медичним працівникам
та сподіватися, що ми усіх врятуємо.
Ґабріела Паулі отримала першого листа
від департаменту охорони здоров’я.
Якщо вона не вакцинується, їй загрожує
штраф до 2500 євро,
а пізніше вона може втратити свою роботу.
Парламент Німеччини сьогодні
працює понаднормово.
За одну сесію до опівночі
потрібно ухвалити багато законів.
Вже ухвалили рішення про широкомасштабне
скасування санкцій
для тих, хто отримує допомогу за проєктом Hartz-4.
Пільги можуть бути зменшені лише у разі
повторного порушення заявки.
Парламент продовжив пільги через
пандемію коронавірусу.
Важлива інформація для багатьох працівників:
фіксована ставка для тих, хто працює з дому,
поширюється і на цей рік.
Сьогодні знову багато хто
насолоджується  літньою погодою,
інші ж, навпаки, готуються
до небезпечної негоди,
яка охопить Північний Рейн-Вестфалію
та рухатиметься далі, продовжить
лютувати завтра також.
Небезпека сильних злив, граду та смерчу.
Як пояснює Крістоф Дестаірель,
не варто недооцінювати цю ситуацію.
Ми у Бад-Ноєнар-Арвайлер. Після катастрофічної
повені не минуло й року.
Готуючись до нових злив, у місті
роздають мішки з піском.
Двір будівельного маркету -
максимум десять мішків на людину.
Утворились дві довгі черги.
Усі говорять, що краще підстрахуватись,
ніж потім знову постраждати від водних мас.
Далі на північ, на кордоні з Нідерландами,
можна відчути,
як після обіду нагрівається атмосферне повітря.
В Агаусі температура підвищується
майже щохвилини.
Здіймаються сильні пориви вітру,
потім піщана буря і врешті починається гроза.
Така весняна погода не є нормальною.
У нас зараз дуже тепло, навіть спекотно.
До того ж висока вологість.
Це вибухонебезпечна суміш.
І зовсім незвична для травня.
Бурі поширюються з північного заходу.
Північ та південь врятовані,
для інших регіонів прогнози синоптиків невтішні.
Сьогодні все ще не так страшно,
завтра ситуація погіршиться.
Наближається циклон, який
супроводжуватиметься сильними грозами.
Постійні сильні грози, град та шквали ураганів.
Ситуація справді небезпечна.
У Крефельді грози вже досягли руйнівної сили.
Пориви вітру з блискавками уразили цей дах.
Пожежники прибули вчасно
та можуть запобігти спалаху пожежі.
Увечері в Бад-Ноєнар-Арвайлер
знову починаються зливи.
Рівень загрози важко передбачити
в цих екстремальних погодних умовах.
Це був історичний тріумф:
ФК «Айнтрахт» із Франкфурта-на-Майні
вчора в Севільї переміг «Глазго Рейнджерс»
у футбольній Лізі Європи.
Після короткої ночі команда
вже повернулася додому.
О 17:40 літак з Іспанії
приземлився в аеропорту Франкфурта,
Капітан команди Себастьян Роде та
тренер Олівер Гласнер
першими зійшли з літака з трофеєм,
а команда зараз у дорозі до ратуші Römer у Франкфурті.
Тисячі вболівальників «Айнтрахта»
годинами чекали там,
щоб відсвяткувати разом зі своїми героями.
Маркус Волзіффер зараз там.
Площа переповнена, чи є там місце для «Айнтрахту»?
Думаю, на балконі ще є трохи місця,
тут внизу буде надто тісно.
Допускається 13 тис. глядачів, більше не пускають.
Загалом поліція очікує близько 100 тис.
Місце зустрічі на річці Майн є надзвичайно популярним.
Команда приземлилася вчасно, що можна
побачити на екрані.
Вдоволення юрби є безмежним.
Трофей наближається до ратуші.
Спочатку команда хоче поставити
свій підпис у Золотій книзі,
а тоді капітан команди вийде на балкон та підійме кубок
вгору. Ми схвильовані, це була вражаюча перемога.
Звичайно, усі стривожено дивляться вгору:
гримить та йде дощ.
Цікаво, що буде далі.
Дякую, Марк, за репортаж з місця подій!
Найбільший успіх в історії клубу,
шаленство фанів та вечірка в Römer, -
про це розкажуть о 19:30 колеги з «Heute Live».
А зараз Катя розповість про спортивну частину
цього дивовижного успіху.
Глядачам також довелося запастись
терпінням та нервами,
адже цей фінал, як і личить
справжньому футбольному фіналу,
визначив переможця через серію пенальті.
Підсумковий рахунок 6:5 проти «Глазго Рейнджерс»
став початком довгого святкування.
Невелика кількість вболівальників,
які були присутніми на матчі,
співочим виступом святкують перемогу у Севільї.
Рафаель Борре забив вирішальний гол
у серії пенальті для ФК «Айнтрахт» з Франкфурта.
Хвиля ентузіазму прокотилася
від Андалузії до Франкфурту,
де десятки тисяч святкують
першу перемогу Німеччини
у Лізі Європи та не можуть в це повірити.
Цього року нам пощастило,
хоча ми і раніше добре грали.
І так, ми неймовірно пишаємося тим,
що опинилися в центрі уваги Німеччини.
Очікувалось, що це буде складна та серйозна гра.
57 хвилина: Джо Арібо виводить
«Рейнджерс» уперед.
«Айнтрахт» швидко зрівнює рахунок.
На 69-й хвилині Рафаель Борре забиває гол,
рахунок 1:1, додатковий час.
Кевін Трапп відбиває пас у ворота «Айнтрахта»
незадовго до закінчення.
Після цього він відбиває удар
Аарона Ремзі у пенальті.
Звання володаря Кубка Європи,
Ліга чемпіонів наступного року у кубку 1,
Суперкубок, навіть не знаю, як його назвати.
Йдеться про Суперкубок у серпні
проти переможців Ліги чемпіонів,
«Мадрида» чи «Ліверпуля».
До того часу команда Олівера Гласнера
може святкувати
свій перший за 42 роки міжнародний
командний тріумф.
Тим часом ФК Бундесліги «Вольфсбург»
знайшов у новому тренері те, що шукав.
За повідомленнями ЗМІ,
Ніко Ковач, колишній тренер «Баварії»,
а також ФК «Айнтрахт» Франкфурт,
негайно вступить на посаду.
Ковач також стежить за Флоріаном Кофельдтом,
якого несподівано звільнили в неділю.
Ковач має отримати контракт на 3 роки.
А зараз про чемпіонат світу з хокею у Фінляндії.
Сьогодні в обід команда Німеччини
мала зіграти там свою четверту гру
попереднього раунду проти Данії.
Однак за півгодини до початку гри
зал був повністю пустим.
Через невелику пожежу спрацювала
пожежна сигналізація,
але її швидко загасили.
Німецькі гравці в повному спорядженні
чекали перед залом,
дехто з них стояв вже у ковзанах.
Після цього гра розпочалась, Німеччина перемогла
Данію з рахунком 1:0. Божевілля!
Будьте обережними у штормових регіонах!
Детальніше про це за мить з Крістою Орбен.
О 21:45 в ефірі «Heute Journal» з Крістіаном Зіверсом.
На сьогодні це все.
Команда «Heute» бажає вам приємного вечора.
До завтра!
Вітаю вас на огляді прогнозу погоди!
Серйозна грозова ситуація нависла над нами.
Грози з першим невеликим циклоном,
наче по лінії, рухаються країною,
а завтра, із другим невеликим циклоном,
негода поступово досягне піку.
Все почнеться сьогодні вночі.
Лінія з грозами переміщається трохи на схід,
далі тягнеться від Північної Баварії
до Балтійського моря.
Однак у другій половині ночі усе припиниться.
На заході країни знову зростає ризик негоди.
Завтра вранці гроза досягне центральної частини країни.
Поки що там сухо та спокійно.
Однак у другій половині дня розпочнуться
сильні грози, схожі на буревій,
ми попереджаємо про сильний дощ
зі швидкістю понад 40 міліметрів на годину,
який може спровокувати локальні повені.
Також очікується сильний град та пориви вітру.
Можливі навіть смерчі.
Усе розпочнеться після обіду на заході країни,
а ввечері досягне також і східної частини.
Бережіть себе!
Температура вночі досягне 10-17 градусів,
завтра впродовж дня 18-25 градусів на півночі.
На півдні знову спекотно, до 34 градусів,
а на вихідних погода нормалізується.
До побачення!